in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
I'm in the sauce for clinic Berlin at
the Department for neurology and I'm
with Professor Thomas leopard thanks for
inviting me into your clinic hello I'm a
GP myself and I see many patients with
the complained of dizziness or vertigo
and sometimes the patient's just sheer
panic because it's so afraid of this
condition so how how dangerous is it
normally it's not dangerous at all
patients often have the sensation of
panic as you tell us but normally it's
totally harmless only one or two percent
of dizziness patients really have a
severe underlying condition so it's all
about the underlying condition or not
about the symptom yes and how do you
diagnose the underlying condition and so
most important is spending time with a
patient listening to the patient and
asking the right questions so one
question would be what type of dizziness
do you experience any spinning of
vertigo type of dizziness or just a
general dizziness do you how long do
your attacks last do you have extra
symptoms like hearing loss or tinnitus
on neurological symptoms and if I know
enough about the dizziness as if I had
experienced it myself then I usually
know what the diagnosis is so we nearly
feel the diagnosis after there and if
you don't know it by then then you're
putting the patient into this kind of
lab we're standing in here right now now
that step in between would we need to do
a physical examination because often I
can see by hand what's wrong but often I
use the lab as well to specifically
check the vestibular system the balance
system in dena year okay so we have a
very healthy young men today with us
he's not a patient and he doesn't
complain of any dizziness but you can
show some of the examination you do yes
yes and and the core test probably is
the caloric test which means that by
temperature you can activate your
balance organ in the inner ear or can
inhibit it with cold water or warm water
and then we we measure the reactions of
the eyes so an eye movement would be the
expected response and if he doesn't have
a response on one ear but on the other
one I I would know that he has a loss on
that function loss on that side so how
do you feel right now it's dark but I'm
fine no sickness and no business so this
kind of machinery is not usually in the
setting of novel pressure CVP practice
but what we do have actually there is
this kind of glasses yeah for the
friends of glasses yeah so what do you
do with those yes they serve to enlarge
the eyes at the same time the patient
doesn't see you right through these big
lenses and this helps us to observe the
eyes and also the patient cannot fix
eight so so if i would have a vertical
ratify woodfield again you can see it in
my oven yes we can make you dizzy easily
okay yeah you can simply turn on the
spot just five times and then we will
see what happens okay it's a medical
mary go round okay and right on this
spot you turn around five times yeah
it's very good two three four one more
and I'll stop and open your eyes and we
can see your eyes and beach to the right
side this is what we call in this tag
miss and then the status indicates that
your balance organs are activated which
is hopefully good thing after i try to
run yes this is a healthy reaction but
if you see this in a patient who has not
moved like you did before then you know
something's wrong in the balance system
so this is one of those examinations you
do in a frequent basis so feeling dizzy
or vertigo is a thing combined of
different systems in the body one is the
eyes
the ears and the muscles and the brain
and it has to work together in a very
special way many's disease is one of the
causes of vertigo and dizziness but
there are different causes yes there are
quite a few and and the very harmless
one would be circulatory collapse or a
pre syncopal feeling where you almost
faint when you get up too quickly but
the more common causes maybe migraine
but also positional vertigo which is
short but very intense spinning whenever
you turn over in bed or when you get up
from lying and then how do you treat the
feeling of dizziness first you have to
find out what it is and then for example
if you have circulation problems you try
to raise the blood pressure but when
it's migraine you may succeed with
medication but very often you don't need
medication and instead you use
physiotherapy for example positional
maneuvers for positional vertigo or
balance retraining programs it's very
important to activate the patient there
are exercises that patients can do at
home and and this is very effective also
psychologically if you can do something
for yourself and you can show us the
maneuver how to get rid of positional
yes yes that's easy please come in and
have a seat here so I would ask you to
lie down to that side and first turn
your head to the opposite side and now
one two three go and look at my forehead
and then I watched the patient's eyes
and when they start to beat and its
toughness like this then I know it's
this year that has got positional
vertigo and the left ear yeah the lake
house its ear which is down he's not
moving his eyes at all no he's healthy
healthy good for you but if I had seen
the nystagmus I could immediately do the
therapeutic maneuver to relieve him so
we could simulate that yes so we tried
one two three go and there he is that's
the second position
and he just wears rests there for
another 30 seconds and this is because
their little tiny crystals inside the
ear they're displaced and by that
maneuver and there are other maneuvers
as well but by that menu I can
reposition them to where they belong and
then finally patient sits up and that
was it for seventy percent of the
patients just a single maneuver is
enough and otherwise you do a few
repetitions so it works like magic
physiotherapy em is another way to treat
different causes and of the Sentinel
dizziness so you can show some yes this
is here okay so almost any type of
dizziness that is that goes along with
the balance problem can be treated by
physical exercises he's on a cushion yes
you don't need extra equipment and the
the role of the physiotherapist is to
customize these exercises to your limit
of capabilities so that you can expand
your balance functions and when patients
have learned this and have a little
program for for training at home they
can do it every day once or twice for
several minutes and then they will
improve and they will feel a lot better
and even if they don't suffer from
vertigo or dizziness if you grow older
and you practice it you can prevent
false yes absolutely it's we know that
physiotherapy works in an excellent way
to prevent Falls and hip fractures
that's a good thing to start this today
even if you don't feel dizzy think so
much for inviting me into your clinic
you